so uh welcome eric eric is a member of
the condaforge core team and has been
involved since its beginnings at scipy
2015.
professionally he's currently at voltron
data product managing the enterprise
offering previously he has held a
variety of roles including director of
data science platform at dtn
principal solutions architect at
anaconda
computational engineer in edtech at
point
and assistant scientist and post-doc at
brookhaven national lab
he holds a phd in chemistry though was
not a particularly good chemist and is
much better suited to tech and eric is
going to give us an update on conor
forge in 2021 thank you florian
uh let me share my screen
um please feel free to interrupt
at any time um i will uh keep an eye on
chad and q a and kind of you know
address them as they come up um cool so
we've got a uh condo forge is a pretty
enormous team here um we pulled
the
uh github avatars for you know
some of the
main teams here we have a very active
we're
we have a reasonably large core team
there's
25 of us kind of here on the right of
the side uh we've also got what's called
an emeritus core team
that's up here in the top left
those are folks that have been active at
one point but have chosen to step away
for you know a variety of reasons
there's a large team that manages our
staged recipes and if all of these words
are not making any sense just give it uh
about
three to four slides and things will
start to make sense
um
we've got a stage recipes team that's
that's uh these 12 folks here and then
there's a whole uh
there's a whole lot of other people that
are maintaining uh the recipes that make
the kind of packages that we all use on
a day-to-day basis our core team
is involved in a very broad variety of
communities we've got a couple folks
from bioconda
um
you know who are the current condolent
over at anaconda you know there's a guy
at cern
um
not to read off the uh the the whole
slides here
um but you know
there's folks that are contributing to
error and parquet we've got the mamba
primary author
um jupiter hub
folks here astro pi
uh it's a pretty
it's pretty uh it's pretty broad-ranging
community that that has hooks into a lot
of places quick outline uh
you know gonna cover just kind of what
is conda what's the ux today
go over some fun
numbers and then go over you know the
architecture and
some of the design constraints have gone
to forge and then how to get involved at
the end there will be lots of time for
questions uh
now and uh throughout
okay so quickly what is conda uh it's a
cross-platform package manager meaning
that
you can install packages on you know
most all common hardware that exists
uh today um
there was a question earlier in our
public getter channel you know does it
work in docker and the answer is yes uh
it works it works anywhere that
you can run conda basically
which is docker on your local machine
cloud hpc i
think it would work in embedded i know
it works on raspberry pi it's been
around for a little over 10 years uh
created back in 2011 by anaconda to
solve
the scientific packaging problem uh it
was it was becoming extremely hard to
install things like numpy and scipy with
the built-in python package with the
setup tools approach
um so anaconda went to the core team
python
basically said hey can we work with you
to solve this scientific packaging
problem they said no go and solve it
yourself so they did and that's where
conda came from
and i should note that anaconda in 2011
was called continuum analytics
uh it's way broader than just python
we've got support for all of the
languages listed on the on the third
bullet
i will note that if you're familiar with
gpu accelerated computing uh it's how
nvidia
or it's how the rapids team does all of
their package management that and docker
and conda obviates the need for
compilers on the
on the user system because it uh puts
the load on the
package authors uh so you only have to
compile it once
instead of every user having to have all
of the compilers
uh to install your packages or to
install your code
uh
from source
um quick getting started uh
these are all active links there's
there's a lot of links scattered
throughout here the docs are fairly
robust in terms of all of this on the
left if if you're familiar with you know
using python from anaconda um you may be
familiar with some of the syntax here
so creating a con environment to do it
from condo forge you just need to add
the condo forge channel that's this
yellow bit here if you if you use the
mini conda images from anaconda
we've got similar ones from the condo
forge
organization on docker
we do not manage anything like the
anaconda
uh
distribution that is an extreme amount
of work on the anaconda side we do not
have the staff
nor really the charter to go and solve
that kind of a problem
but there are many many
uh
teams and companies uh that build their
own internal
uh
distributions from the condo forge
packages that are
available um
if you use the mini conda installer we
have similar installers uh called
miniforge and
mambaforge those are available
basically in the outer product of these
four columns here so they're available
in both an install script and a docker
image with conden mamba for a couple
flavors of python on a wide variety of
platforms
you can get
you can get the mini conda
or you can get the mini fortune mama
forge
releases from the link in the top right
and the docker images also from the link
in the top right
um
again this link here i will take you
through a much more verbose version of
you know what's the contributor
user experience
um this slide is mostly just to kind of
walk you through if you're not familiar
um
i'm already 10 minutes in and the vanity
metrics are way more fun does it work
with alpine
uh i will take that as a note and get
back to you on slack um
uh
there's so many questions like this i'm
not you know i don't want to speak
incorrectly so i will get back to you on
that
um if you if you're on twitter give me
your twitter handle and i'll at you from
the official condo forge account
um
the oh sorry the question was uh does
condo forge work
with alpine
um
yeah so again uh this is a lot of text
on here there's really
there's a couple of things to point out
um we are available on gitter uh gitter
is a live chat service that's free kind
of i think it predates slack or was kind
of
came into vogue about the same time that
slack was gaining uh its
popularity so if you need live chat and
just like kind of you want to ask a live
question that isn't really a good place
for a github issue
please do please feel free to use either
of the links here um
when you release a new version well uh
we've got a bot that automatically goes
and tries to find or that that goes and
grabs
that version
uh and updates your condo recipe and the
feed stock um again i'm not going to go
through this slide in great detail
the fun part is the vanity metrics
which i wanted to spend some time on
we have three thought we have over 3 300
individuals that have committed to
maintain packages
um they have admin on one or more
repositories in the condo forge
ecosystem
there's 25 of us that have kind of admin
rights over the whole org
for almost up to 16 000 libraries that
that can be installed
via conda
our bot has issued over a hundred
thousand
prs i think 105 of those have actually
been merged
uh in terms of individual artifacts
these 15 000 libraries uh
turn into 708 000 total packages
um
3.6 terabytes of storage for all of
those packages oh i should have done uh
total traffic
i'll i'll have to add that for the next
time i give this talk in 2022.
uh we're a little over 5 billion
downloads since uh anaconda started
keeping track of our daily downloads
that was in march 2017
would maybe add a little bit if if they
if they had kept track since the
inception in 2015 but
uh it's a pretty small tale
at that point we are almost at 300
million monthly downloads as of
last month uh
less than
a million away
uh and for most of this year
uh we've had more downloads than uh the
anaconda channel
now it's possible that's because
anaconda did change their terms of
service to try and uh drive some
business value for them
um
and so you know
either way it's still a lot of it's a
lot of traffic
uh and we support six platforms
uh that's listed in the second two last
bullet
um
charts wise so the top is our is the
download count for condo forge and
anaconda
in green and yellow
uh the bottom chart is for the smaller
is for the
um
smaller channels you know plus here for
just a second intake support
okay
um
condo forge works via
free ci services that folks have donated
in kind
this is the number of builds per day
that we have that we're doing on our
various
ci systems azure pipelines is
by a very wide margin the most heavily
trafficked
um
microsoft very generously donated 200
parallel build builds for condo forge
um
we do a lot of github actions as well uh
condo forge was
created initially using travis ci for
uh
mac build circle for linux and app fair
for windows
and so we still
use those a little bit but not to the
extent that we
did at one point
um
you know the number of packages over
time since july since february i think
of 2018
has been growing fairly
consistently month over month
um you know and then the
total size here
um
there's a lot of different components of
condo forge if you've ever submitted a
pull request to add a new library you've
interacted with the stage recipes team
they're with the stage recipes
repository
on
condo forge
from stage recipes
[Music]
what's called a feedstock is created
that is a git repository that the recipe
maintainers have full admin on
ci services are hooked up to
those feedstocks via our automation
and packages are built on the ci
services and pushed up to a staging
channel
and then we have a
um web service that then goes and
validates that that the artifacts are
what they're supposed to and then uh
promotes them to the
main channel
uh we have a whole separate bot
organization
that um
you know does stuff like auto like
it's got the automated management of the
feedstocks down so you can ask it to you
know update your
update your uh
your feedstock for the latest version of
python you can ask it to add the mac
builds for the new mac chips
um it handles monitoring for
new builds
uh
all right i see a new question coming i
will
all right um
etc
uh
so
um
adam when that question comes in i will
pause and read it off and then answer it
um
condo forge uh there's
we don't own any infrastructure so we
don't own any hardware
that does any builds um other than you
know individual dev laptops that we
sometimes need for very specific long
builds like like qt
uh there's nobody who's paid that's uh
to
work on condo forge um if there's you
know if you want to get involved
uh just start doing stuff um you know
we'll probably add you to
the various teams you know we uh
we love it when folks get involved
because you know it means that we can
now cover other things or that there's
new
um use cases
that we can go and uh
uh solve for
uh we don't have any recurring revenue
so there's no sales team there's no you
know products that folks buy you know
there are there have been a few uh
donations over the years um individuals
are are supporting
condo forage uh but you know there's no
money coming in we managed to bootstrap
the whole thing on i think we've spent
less than ten thousand dollars ever all
time
um
so there's a question in the chat uh
give a quick give a quick overview of
cod to forge as it compares to other
package managers why is condo forge
special um
condo forge and conda are so condo forge
is one
source for condo packages conda is the
package manager
um
the
most package managers are either
language specific
or
platform specific so you know apt and
yum etc on linux you've got things like
homebrew and macports on mac you've got
uh
the windows one
chocolatey i think is the windows one
um
and then you know there's pip and wheels
but pip is very python specific
um
so condo forge is really one of the only
you know
cross-platform things that gives you the
same commands on linux and windows and
os x and
uh all of the other platforms that
we talked about i should go to the next
slide
while i talk about this um did that
answer your question adam
um and if not uh perhaps a follow-up and
i will address that in a minute
there are
four major
goals uh
that we have in condo forge uh as listed
in the left
um of this slide
um you know we want to be as transparent
as possible uh
it's
it's just kind of a core design goal
that we have uh when
when there's no secrecy when there's no
like
this
this build got created on someone's
laptop and we're not sure of its
provenance um
i guess what what i'm trying to say here
is the transparency build stress um and
condo forge only works as the central
place for community conduct package
management uh when there's trust
uh we have you know a couple of
aspirational goals uh it'd be great if
every possible package that exists on
condo forge can be installed with every
other package
um
obviously that's
an instrument and
an infeasible task to achieve in reality
uh
but i would say that condo forge has a
you know eventually compatible model um
over time packages will usually end up
working together because somebody will
hit an issue and then go and figure out
why and fix it
we have another aspirational goal of you
know we would like to be able to coexist
with anaconda
there have been times in the in in the
past like
you know 2019-ish and earlier when it
was
almost a guaranteed failure if you were
installing from the anaconda channels
and from the condo forged channels uh
that is we you know
did we
went through a pretty herculean effort
to standardize compilers and tool chains
across uh anaconda and condo forge to
reduce that burden
um this only works via a heavy dose of
automation
uh and so there's you know lots of
automation here
uh and then
um
the core team of condo forge doesn't
really own anything i mean
we have admin on 16 000 git repositories
but the
the condo forge ecosystem heavily relies
on the you know over 3000 individuals
that are
maintaining um
the kind of recipes uh and creating
builds as
new versions of their libraries um are
made
uh let's see last slide if you want to
get involved um here's a little you know
if you like the thing on the left go
check out the thing on the right
um you know if you want to grow the
capabilities of what you can install
with conda start getting involved in the
staged recipes team uh that's you know
github.com condo forge slash staged
recipes i'll just put that in chat
stage recipes
um
if you really like maintenance and
keeping things running um you know
there's a list of under-maintained feed
stocks that's where condo packages come
from
uh you know just hop in our getter
channels and start answering questions
or asking questions uh
read through the docs and make things
clearer
when they're not clear
if you really like automation we have a
bot team that uh
is also
like-minded and super obsessed
with automation there are links on the
slide for how to get involved there
um then if you want to financially
support condo forge uh there's a couple
of paths there there's you know
donations through
focus and there's donations of you know
servers and hardware and stuff
servers is a little challenging we're
working with quansite
to
[Music]
get some gpu servers so that we can
actually do gpu enabled builds
um
but that is it for now
um
thank you all for listening um and with
that uh i will have oh there we go
can you talk to some of the efforts
around the mamba project bow etcetera
yeah so
um well hold on that's a that's a good
question i'm going to go to the next one
first uh awesome on the forge what's the
best slash easiest way to set up a
company internal mirror of condo forge
save us from traffic um
so
uh i would say set up your own mirror if
you want to own your uh availability um
traffic is generously paid for by
anaconda uh that they've you know they
they spend a lot of time you know
sending packages to a globally
distributed cdn
um i guess that's the same that's a
redundant statement but whatever um
uh so you know another set of thanks to
anaconda there uh there's a library that
i wrote called condom mirror uh i will
add that as well github.com slash panda
incubator
slash condom mirror
that basically does that for you or it's
it's the way that you can get packages
from
uh anaconda.org to inside of your
firewall
um
beware of that if you're a company do
not mirror the anaconda channels there's
a terms of service on there
i would also highly encourage you to
look at their paid offering um
just simply because you know having
maintained an internal mirror and i know
exactly what you're signing yourself up
for
i think their pricing is fairly
reasonable so if you've you know i would
definitely get in touch with anaconda i
believe it's called anaconda team
edition
uh okay jason so talk some of the
efforts around mamba bow etc yeah so
uh
the quant stack team led by sylvan
corley uh
they are a team of really really good c
plus plus devs uh they wrote like the
zeus project um
uh
[Music]
which is uh writing c plus plus in like
jupiter like kernels which is a very
strange thing that i've never really
wrapped my head around fully but anyways
um the condo solver ended up getting
progressively slow or
as the
number of packages that were available
that you needed to account for to solve
an environment grew
um and eventually the condo solver just
wasn't able to keep up and you know
sometimes we would encounter solve times
of you know 10 minutes then 15 minutes
then 30 minutes then an hour and
sometimes it just would never solve um
mamba was a re-implementation of the
core solving logic in c plus to make it
a lot faster
and most places have have switched over
to mamba full time
the anaconda team that's maintaining
conda and condo build
are working on making conda plugable so
so that we could use the mamba so that
conda can basically say i want to use
the mamba solver
as my back end um
and you know that opens the door for
other kinds of implementations that
solve other problems
uh boa is a similar style
for condo build
it's
i think it's implementing more
so mamba is predominantly using the
python apis from conda plus undo c plus
plus solver um boa is the c plus plus i
think it's a re-implementation of most
of condu build in
2 plus there's also kind of a hybrid
if you do
conda mamba
build
which i just put in chat
if you do conda mamba build
that gives you the
mamba solver but the conda build
uh
uh
librarian cli
um
yeah perfect thank you jason
um we
are so condo forge is both is is is
extremely friendly with the anaconda
uh team and with the and with the
folks that build mamba um and i think
have managed to broker you know a little
bit
uh
of
some
uh good community uh shifts there
um
let me see if there's anything cool i
think i think that's it on the q a um
i'll be around on the pi data global
slack uh feel free to ping me there
thank you all for listening
bye